hello my name is daniele podini i am the
department chair
at george washington university in the
department of forensic sciences
i'm also a forensic molecular biology
and today i will be talking to you about
some of the research that we've been
doing
in my laboratory the title of the talk
is microhapa types the next generation
of forensic dna
markers
so mixtures dna mixtures they represent
probably one of the greatest challenges
in forensic dna analysis
there's many reasons for that sample
degradation
can affect the the quality of the of the
mixture
allele sharing between contributors uh
allele dropout um and pcr artifacts
such as stutter and this is obviously
with the conventional
dna marker used in in
our field which are short tandem repeats
mastery parallel sequencing of sdrs or
short tandem repeats
can increase the ability
of the convoluted mixtures the
fact that we can sequence sdr and e
alleles can
enable the individualization of some
alleles that have the same
size but different sequences it can also
allow to minimize fragment length so we
can increase
the the sensitivity of the assay when
the dna is degraded
and in some cases it can distinguish
between a stutter so
an artifact of a major contributor in a
mixture
with an allele that overlaps convention
normally would overlap with
with a stutter of the major contribution
of the minor contributor and so
if we can distinguish those by by
sequence
that obviously is an advantage in
determining for example the number of
contributors and determine the ratio
between the major and the minor
and obviously in the past couple of
years
we've seen uh probabilistic genotyping
and really help mixture deconvolution
uh via sdrs but when we talk about
massively parallel sequencing
this um theoretical advantage that it
would offer
is is actually not not so
straightforward here we have an example
of allele 22 of a locus one of the codis
loci
d12 and the allele 20 the sequence of
allele 22
has in this particular case
13 agat and then
8 agac and 1 ag
18. and if you look in position
of allele 21 and also from allele 20
there's uh
there's two stutter so a minus horse
excuse me a one is minus four stutter
that is
actually composed of of two different
sequences in fact
during the the creation of the stutter
so the the slippage of the polymerase
we have a loss uh 60 16
of that stutter is a loss of one repeat
so it goes from
13 agad to 12 but the ag ac remain eight
whereas six percent of the stutter
or six percent of the whole percentage
is um
a slippage at the agac so from one
single allele
allele 22 which is the original allele
of the
individual the actual dna contributor we
have
two different stutters and then we have
the stutter of the stutter
and then we have the plus four stutter
so with a single a single allele
we're actually generating another five
artifacts
so if you can imagine that if there's a
minor contributor there
whose dna is at the level of the stutter
it gets really difficult to interpret
which
leo is an actual artifact versus
one being a stutter obviously if it's in
stutter position
so although
mastery power secret has the potential
to increase the capability of the
convoluting mixtures
it still has a lot of challenges and and
to model
these different types of artifacts in
probabilistic genotyping
it's very complex it's not something
that's really straightforward
and this is where micro hypertypes come
in microhepatites are
novel forensic dna marker
that was initially thought by professor
ken
kidd from yale university and
what they are are a set of snips within
a fragment that can be amplified so
approximately you know 300 nucleotides
or less and
the smaller these fragments the greater
their sensitivity in
indeed degraded dna and in this fragment
that can be amplified we have multiple
snips
and the pattern of these things so the
association between the step alleles
creates different haplotypes so normally
with the sanger sequencing which is the
kind of the old sequencing method that's
been used uh for
several years the entire human genome uh
project was based with
sanger was based on sanger sequencing uh
you see right there you see a gc
sorry a cg a cg and then to a
g's and we don't know based on on
sanger sequencing if that first c is
associated to the second c
or whether it's associated to the g
meaning on which chromosome they are
but with massively parallel sequencing
we can actually separate the two
chromosome because we clonally sequence
each individual chromosome and so in
this case we're able to see that one
haplotype so
for example the one that's inherited by
the father we have a c
c h a and whereas the other chromosome
is ggg
and so those two are essentially those
two haplotypes are essentially two
alleles but you can have multiple
combinations
okay so that's what a micro haplotype is
and the advantages of using micro
haplotypes are several
they uh first of all there's no
stutter because there's there's not a
sequence that's repeated multiple times
as the polymerase amplifies that region
there's no slippage and obviously they
can be selected appropriately so
so the the efficiency of the
amplification
is high they are snips
so uh they're based on snips so the
mutation rate
is a lot lower than short tandem repeats
and
so they they they can be very useful in
uh
relationship testing they um
can be useful because of the stutter
and because there's this uh
[Music]
because there's no stutter in an
imbalanced mixture
you and you would not have the issue
that you have with sdrs where
stutters can overlap with alleles of the
minor contributor that
that issue is absent modeling in
probabilistic genotyping
is much easier because you don't have
the stutter issue at all
and also all the alleles within the same
locus have the same size with strs
you may have alleles that are much
larger than others
because they may have a lot more teeth
and so this gives a
the larger allele an amplification
disadvantage
if there's inhibition or if the dna is
degraded so
you don't have that issue so
there are several advantages there are
some disadvantages of course
for example they are less polymorphic
than sdrs
so you need to increase the number of
law style that you amplify that you
co-amplify
in multiplex to get the same power of
discrimination that you have with sdrs
so designing a multiplex assay may be
more complex
and obviously although i don't have it
on this slide they're based on massively
parallel sequencing which is
more expensive at least right now and
going forward i think uh
massively parallel sequencing will
improve throughput will increase there
will be
a better way to increase the number of
samples that you cannot
analyze at the same time and so there's
you know it's very promising
so in as i said earlier
professor kidd is the one that thought
of this and he started publishing paper
the first paper was as i showed here in
2013
and there were and he was the one that
mostly published
for the first five years on this but
then there was an explosion of
of uh papers and there's actually
more that are that have come out and are
coming out
uh including a couple that we submitted
and we're waiting for
the reviewers to get back to us
and so the community has really
there's consensus in the community that
this is actually a good
forensic dna market so we received
funding from nij to develop an assay
based on a panel that was identified by
dr kidd in collaboration with others
including our group
we selected a subset of this panel based
on two parameters
one is e or effective number of alleles
and the other parameter was uh is
informativeness so the effective number
of audio
is essentially um how it tells us
how discriminating is this particular
locus
so essentially the the
distribution of the alleles that this
particular locus has
and and how balanced this the allele
frequency of the ldls that
are identified for the strokes the
informativeness
instead tells us how
unique are certain alleles to certain
populations so
in essence ae allows us to discriminate
individuals
within the same population or across
population within whereas the
informativeness a higher information
gives us
the ability to discriminate between
individuals from different populations
so we selected a panel based on that and
uh we
uh analyzed multiple samples the
throughput uh the
process of the analysis was uh first the
library preparation we did both manual
and using students as part of their
projects
and also automated library prep
then we did what's called ship
templating well the templating and
loading on the chip so
so the libraries get go through a
process of a motion pcr
and then eventually they get purified
and loaded onto the chip
and then they were sequenced on the ion
s5 so this is the
ion s5 mps platform
then we worked on
pipelines for bioinformatic pipelines to
process the data
using some that were provided by thermal
fissures
other others that we developed and the
final output
in this particular case kind of mimics
what the
conventional sdr analysis looks like so
we have a in this case we have a bar as
opposed to having a peak and the height
of the bar
represents how many individual reads of
that particular sequence
have been found and at the bottom you
see
a g and gg are the two alleles meaning
a and one on one chromosome we have
at the first snip and a at the second
snippet g
in the other chromosome we have two g's
and these are not necessarily contiguous
they can be separated as i showed you in
the previous slide
and we did several studies so i'm going
to go through some of them here
uh i don't have time to go through all
of them but
if anybody's interested they can contact
me
so we did a mixture study oh
the first is the sensitivity so the
sensitivity that we
we were able to obtain we obtained full
profiles down to 50 picograms of input
dna
which is very similar if not better than
most of the conventional sdr kits that
are commercially used by crime labs
right now
so we developed multiple mixtures
starting from 10 to 1 to
twenty to one forty to one even down to
eighty to one
and and then we did multiple
contributors and and
this slide kind of shows you the
distribution of types of mixtures that
we looked at
we obtained the full profiles for most
of them obviously as we
increase the ratio between the major and
the minor we're
we're inputting always less amount of
dna of the minor given that
the overall amount of dna as you can see
on the right of the slide
is one nanogram so as you increase the
ratio between the two
you're always putting in less and less
of the minor contributor so we started
seeing some
as expected some allele dropout and the
20 to one
a lot of allele dropout in the 40 to 1
and the complete dropout of the minor
contributor in there in the 80 to 1
which was expected
we analyzed those mixtures in multiple
ways so we used our
micro haplotype assay we also used
the conventional global filer kit with
the capillary electrophoresis
the 24 loci assay that is
you know been validated in many
laboratories and then we use the
the new precision id global filer engine
s
ngs sdr panel version two and that is
that includes all the 24 low side that
are in the conventional ce
a global filer plus an additional set of
lost eye
that increase the power discrimination
of the assay
so we analyze the same mixture with the
same amount of dna
in these three different ways and here
are the data
so this is an example we're talking
about sensitivity
22 a 20 to 1 ratio as we expect we see
some dropout of the minor contributor
with conventional c so for example
at locus d3 we see the 16 and the 18 of
the minor contributor that are very low
the wwa we see the 18 then we see some
dropout
and some are masked so for example at
local css
1po the minor contributor is who is
number 12 which is obviously masked
in this case by the major who is 912.
the to 421 ratio as as we
expect that we don't see any of the
minor contributor
with this conventional ce
when looking at the same
samples but tested with massively
parallel
sequencing gobo filer kit
we end up getting a little bit more
information of the minor contributor
and again this the the just navigates
you through this plot
the height of the bar represents the
individual sequences
and um the number underneath each bar
represents the allele call
and that so these are sequenced meaning
the software
reads the the sequence uh
that's that's generated by the secrecy
on the chip
and then it counts the individual
repeats and then it
develops this this output so it's it's
um
kind of an our artificial really
artificial output as opposed to
the peaks that we were seeing in the
previous slide
which are you know the height of the
peak is actually a consequence of the
amount of fluorescence that is generated
by the pcr product as it goes through
the capillary
and so almost complete dropout
well so at the 21 ratio we see a lot of
the minor contributor more than we were
seeing with
ce in the 40 to 1 ratio essentially we
see a complete dropout
we see a few elevated stutters like in
d4 s 2408 we see a little bit
of the 10 that is
slightly above the stutter threshold but
this is
cannot be considered reliable because
we haven't this is a new kit we hadn't
done a thorough
actual internal validation so we don't
have stutter threshold we're just using
the ones that are
produ that were given by default and
again there's
there's not been enough processing of
this kit to be able to determine whether
that 10 is actually
above the stutter threshold meaning
there's the minor contributors
that's increasing the the read count
uh okay now the same mixtures
with uh micro haplotypes we see
a significant amount of alleles of the
minor contributor
at the 20 to 1 ratio where
at the 40 to 1 ratio obviously we have
more dropout but we're still detecting
a good amount of alleles of the minor
54 to be to be specific and
22 alleles of the minor contributor and
we'll see
later i have a slide showing that the
random match probability that is
generated
with just these 22 alleles of the minor
contributor
is sufficient is strong is pretty
powerful we're getting you know
uh one in a million or around that area
so
so we're going from a stick up sorry
um a profile that's analyzed with ce
that yields nothing
40 to 1 we didn't get anything to
something that can give us a random
match probability of one in a minute so
it's a it's a very
powerful technique now
the idea here okay we've seen that it
actually has the potential
of i'm not gonna say replace sdrs
because
sdrs are here to stay there's an
enormous
enormous inertia of you know the
convicted offender database that has
you know millions and millions of
profiles
sdr profiles there's forensic profiles
within codis that are obviously useful
potentially useful to identify offenders
that haven't been
officially typed yet so sdrs are here to
stay but it has the potential
to enhance mixed deconvolution or to
complement sdrs
but in order for this to happen we have
to make them attractive to
forensic scientists so so how can we
make them attractive so
um first of all there has to be
user-friendly software
and that makes it easier uh
to to look at the sample and it has to
be robust
developing a bioinformatic pipeline is
not
as easy as i thought at least when i got
into this field
you know the converting um
so the out the conventional output is
pretty straightforward from ce
so the the amount of fluorescent
generates a signal
that's detected and kind of plotted into
you know that graphical representation
then
they were so used to the bioinformatics
there's a lot of noise there's so many
more samples it's something that cannot
be done manually
so it's a lot more complex complex
then we need allele frequency because if
we real frequencies are
what allows us to determine the
frequency of a profile so we have a
match between the evidence and
a suspect but we can't just say it's a
match we have to provide
a statistical significance of this match
or call it random match probability
we call it likelihood ratio it depends
and then
they have to be amenable to
probabilistic genotyping
it's the software is complex enough
the the number of lost high are much
greater than
than with sdrs because you want to you
want to
obtain a as i said earlier you you need
more low side
to obtain the same discrimination power
so you can't really do it manually and
as
we've seen in the community everybody's
shifting to probably
genotyping because it makes things so
much
more consistent much more
straightforward our
challenges do it but this is something
that would be a must for micro habitats
to be
implemented and finally there has to be
an international consensus on the on the
final panel
that we want to use as a community and
that
is really crucial and i'm not going to
talk about it now
because i
really haven't been working on this
right now
directly but it's something that's
extremely
important because that is what's going
to allow the companies
that the manufacturers of this kit these
molecular biology kits who
to then decide whether it's worth
investing their resources in developing
a panel so there has to be consensus
between the community on
which are the law sites to type so
user-friendly software
so we here is an example of
a kind of an alpha version of a plugin
for armed expert and this is
thanks to brian young you see his
picture at the bottom of the left
and obviously this doesn't doesn't tell
you much i have i zoomed into one of
them so here
is um just a
plot plotting of the results of a set of
microhaps of our panel the again the
height of the bar
represents the coverage meaning how many
sequences have been identified with that
particular pattern
the label on the top shows you the
allele call
and right now they've been labeled with
with a particular code
but that can be adapted to anything we
want
the loku's name is at the top and
the the two alleles are what you see at
the bottom so the bar represents the
the individual and yield so so as you
can see now this the saw there's some
imbalance this is a single star sample
so ideally
you would want um you know one peak when
the individual's homozygote or two
balanced
sorry bars i should say when
the alleles when there's
when the individual's heterozygote but
we see like in the center where uh
it says unique identification code right
in the center you see that there's two
alleles for that locus and they're
significantly imbalanced there's
almost twice the amount of one versus
the other so
that's a a biopharmatic issue so
we have to optimize the the pipeline
in order to clean better and to identify
which ones are
the actual alleles and and you see a
couple of those
also also we want to try and and and
that's more kind of a
pcr primer concentration as you try to
balance the
all the different low sides so so that
the coverage is similar across the low
side
but this is an example of how we would
want a software so you
kind of select the sample you run the
software and you get these bars and then
obviously the output is that they have
to be exported into a table that can be
used for
uh comparison and if it's a mixture
there could be some
manual interpretation initial manual
interpretation but this is a good way to
visualize
the sample and it's attractive to
old-school
dna analysts that are used to looking at
at peaks
right then the bioinformatician doesn't
really look at this anymore
so this is really for for us uh
molecular biologists or
dna analysts in terms of allele
frequencies
we've uh generated
we've sequenced several samples for
for the purpose of generating allele
frequencies for the
major u.s population so african american
european americans
east asian american southwest hispanics
and we've
typed also um over 800 samples
14 different populations throughout the
world so we we have
the allele frequencies that that can be
used already
on on the set that we've on the 74
types that we've analyzed and we've also
tested how well we could use microhaps
to predict the ancestry of an individual
so
for that we use the allele frequencies
that were generated
for many more populations across the
world by dr
ken kidd and and his lab
and here's an example of how
ancestry prediction could be done so
here these are individuals of african
descent
and what you see uh what you
see is so the plot represents the
frequency of each individual profile
in all the populations that are listed
on the top of that
graph so and these are 20 individuals
of african-american descent so that's
the biogeographic ancestry
and as you can see the frequency of
their profile is
higher in operations from africa
so as you move from from left to right
at a certain point there's a drop which
corresponds to individual
allele frequencies that were from
individuals of european descent
and although on the graph there's not
much
difference but each one of those lines
those
horizontal lines is three orders of
magnitude so
so in essence uh the the
as you drop what is it one two three or
four lines is like 12 orders of
magnitude
difference in terms of the frequency of
that profile in that population
so you clearly see a pattern of
individuals from
of african-american these are europeans
and again you see that their frequency
bumps up when we're using the frequency
the overall frequency of the profile
comes up when you're
when we're looking at uh when we're
using allele frequencies from
european individuals these are
east asians and um
and these are uh software's hispanic
individuals and as
south of hispanics are actually an ad
mix between
europeans and native americans
and you see that the frequency
goes up in both which is what we would
expect here's an example of those are
kind of the averages that i that i
showed you before
and you see also and this is a single
individual in
purple that was a profile from
a native american individual and you see
that the frequency
is relatively low across africa in
europe it goes
out up a bit in east asia and then it
goes up again
significantly up obviously in
when we use the new frequencies from
individuals of
native americans so this shows you that
they actually have the potential to
provide some some ancestry information
and here's kind of a different approach
so we're using a multivariate
statistical approach that
that uses a logistic regression
and pca combined and
these are some of our samples and as you
can see the the plot the individuals are
are well separated into different parts
of the plot
so this is another approach so you would
add an unknown individual
the software would plot it in in one of
these positions and so you could
use this as a as a method to predict the
answers you know we're still working on
this part
but it definitely has potential and this
is in collaboration with
the cabinet group of rome
and the university la sapienza who've
been
using this statistical approach on sdr's
showing some really promising data and
so because microhaps
carry more ancestry information than
sdrs
it is like it these are preliminary data
we're seeing that
that it has the potential to really help
in this
process
this is a kind of an example of
combining
uh mixture interpretation and ancestry
prediction so
on on the left we have the likelihood
ratio of the
observing this particular profile
[Music]
if it's an individual of european
american descent
versus in blue a european uh
an individual uh african-american
descent
meaning that's it's 10 times the 16
times more likely to observe this
particular profile if it's the
european if the dna came from a european
versus an african-american whereas
the red bar shows shows us that it's
about
approximately a thousand times more
likely to observe this profile
if it's an individual of european
descent than if an
individual from hispanics said and um
again european versus asian is a lot
higher so
and this is for the alleles of the minor
contributor
in the 20 to one this is to the left and
to the right
it is for the 40 to 1. on the right side
you see
the random match probability so you see
that the random match probability
for the profile
is in the and that is kind of the
average
is in you know the 10 to the 19. so
we're talking
trillions of trillions so it's a very
very high number
um and this is for the minor contributor
of the twenty to one
the minor contributor of the forty to
one uh that profile is around
uh one in a million so it's still uh
pretty strong although the ancestry
information that we're getting out of
the 40-1
is is not as informative the conclusion
here is that we could say that the
the minor contributor of the 21 mixture
is
um most likely of individual
of european descent possibly hispanic
descent but
we can probably exclude
or assume extremely unlikely that the
individual is
of african-american descent or
east asian americans
probably see genotyping and this is the
research that we're currently working on
so taking the data that
the output data from our bioinformatic
pipelines and then
throwing it into pluralistic genotyping
to see if it works and for this
we've been working on using lr mix
studio which is a semi-continuous model
that basically doesn't look at the
height of the peak so the amount of dna
but simply looks at the presence or
absence of alleles
and then we in collaboration with dr
charles brenner we've been
um using dna view mixture solution who
that was adapted by dr brenner to in
import
inputting or importing
microhap data and i don't have many
examples here
in the interest of time but we've
demonstrated that actually works pretty
well and
microhaps are are a good
a good tool that can be easily adapted
to producing genotyping
because of its characteristics that i
mentioned earlier you don't have to
model stutter
fragment you don't have to model size
between alleles of the same locus as you
have to do with sdrs
and so it's actually working pretty well
and this is an example
of a five-person mixture
where the hypothesis uh are
that um either it's a mixture between
two individual b and c plus three
unknowns
or uh four uh sorry a mixture of five
individuals b and c
but plus three unknowns or b plus plus
four unknowns so it is
essentially the person of interest as mr
c in this case which is
in this particular case was the in
intermediate contributors for the one
that supplied
and so a mixture solution is able to
very effectively deconvolute the mixture
and attribute the alleles to
the different individuals particularly
the intermediate person
and it gives us uh you know one
times 10 to the 78 likelihood ratio
which i don't know even how to say it in
terms of of
um you know trillions of quadrillions or
whatever it is
whereas um alarmic studio it gives us um
you know
eight times 10 to three so you would say
it's 8 000 times more likely to observe
this mixture if it's the mixture between
bc
and three unknowns that fits the mixture
between b and four unknowns
and we we expect that alarmic studio
doesn't have the same power
of of the convolution because
it's not using peak height or in this
case coverage
so this kind of demonstrates that these
are
[Music]
microhappens are a good marker for for
probabilistic genotyping
now we wanted to take it a step uh
further so we we've been focusing
on the snips that define the microhap so
the ones that initially dr
kidd identified these are this is an
example of an amplicon and those red
bars represent the location of the
individual snips
so these are the ones that define the
locus so the
profile you know aaa gg or you know a
at the first red bar a at the second red
bar
g and g at the third and fourth red bars
okay but but there's a lot of real
estate there a lot of
sequences that we've initially been
ignoring so our initial pipeline was
actually only focusing on the four snips
but there's a yeah there's a lot of
potential
uh genetic variation
that can occur there and the the greater
the number
of low side that we're analyzing so the
greater the number of this
this genetic real estate that we're
looking at the greater are the chances
that an individual has a rare snip
that is identified so here is an example
these are the two uh microhaps that
define
the sorry the two snips that define the
microhop
but then if you look at the
all those potential snips that have been
identified
they can there can be variation there
and some of it may be not informative
because maybe it's completely linked
with the allele that we are already
genotyping
but others may not be and here's an
example
of an individual that is homozygote
ga based on uh focusing
on the two snips that define the
microhap but when we actually
go and sequence the individual we see
that there's another
snip variation right there that is
extremely rare
as you can see it's been identified very
rarely
in individuals of african descent
but in it's been virtually not
seen in all the other populations so so
this this
individual now becomes heterozygote so
we goes from homozygote to heterozygote
not only that but it increases the power
of discrimination this profile
incredibly so
in a mixture for example we would be
able to again discriminate
but by adding this rare allele which
would be
gga we increase the
the power of discrimination and the
chances of also
identifying the number of contributors
to a mixture
the next frontier of these microhaps
is already being kind of
addressed by by dr kidd who is now
focused on identifying microhaps that
are
very small and the advantage of these
small microhaps is that they're going to
be a lot more effective
on extremely degraded dna so
sdrs go from approximately 100
onward and with massively parallel
sequencing maybe you can stay within
you know between 100 and 200 250
something like that
so
dna is not that big fragments
but but if the dna is significantly
degraded you're not going to get a good
profile
if you focus on fragments that are
smaller than 50 base pairs
you can you can actually uh increase the
discrimination power
and so here are um here's a
structure plot of 108
microhaps that are smaller than 50 base
pairs and as you can see
they have they have a very good
informativeness
and although it's not shown in the slide
they also have a good
ae so they have a great potential
for typing degraded dna
where sdrs would fail
so here are the various things that
we're still working on
improving our mixture the convolutional
estrogen prediction
degraded dna looking at relationship
testing how effective they are
and not only you know father child but
siblings step siblings
cousins and so forth and we're
in the process of publishing the
allele frequencies and the mixture
studies and also
optimizing the bioinformatic pipeline
which is not a small
undertaker with that i also
want to thank
all the people that worked the data
you've seen there's all my
gw students particularly
fabio ordoni who is
the one on the right of the picture on
the bottom right
you see me ken kidd and
fabio who's done a lot of work here and
also all the the students of the program
uh in this picture there's nina
yeah sharia drew myself and fabio again
so they've they've all
helped a lot and other students that i
wanted there's too many to mention
but also and especially nij for
funding the research that we've been
working on that will help their help
the help of female fisher niche vision
we wouldn't have been able to generate
this data
for that thank you so much